senna je croyais qu'il y avait que des
mines et des corons
on est chez les ch'tis me chez les
picards chez les flamands petit gars un
peu de tenue à la belle-marie cage non
aux grandes pour toi fiston s'y met 25
de hausse en est à londres au moins six
mecs pour la porter tout qu'est même ça
fait six ans entre la tradition et
transmises de générations en générations
de père en fils de la grand mère à sa
toute petite fille et ça serait un
ventre comme c'est pas permis
et là ça balance son monsieur doit pas
être bien loin celle égayant doués du
géant nous est si tu veut traduire les
tout premiers de la région la race des
nobles qui nous visent et celui là avec
sa tête du mineur c'est cafougnette le
toto des gens du nord inventé par un
mini et poète à la petite histoire qui
va avec
oui affamés après cinq ans de travail et
on les parquets ainsi que du bétail dans
les corons c'est du sol un alors là tu
mens prochain coin fiston à quelques
mots près c'est bien ça la mine dis toi
bien que ça s'oublie pas regarde y'a
comme un petit air bégayant ses châteaux
et fillon avec le der des ders le petit
bambin bavard adolescence difficile et
tout et tout comme dans la vie il ya
même des mariages mixtes avec
publication des bans yoplait
tiens v'là les belges et la serre aux
papas et sa petite bonne femme qui vont
négocier quelques centimètres en plus ou
en moins avec les géants de douai va
savoir
il y en a ailleurs au portugal même en
espagne mais les 300 géants du nord
fiston c'est bien de chez nous et c'est
notre patrimoine il y en a qui marc à
ces doses y existe on sait comme de
l'humain c'est fragile mais tu sais ce
que ça veut dire acheter mais c'est une
insulte non un lien du sang une amitié
ça veut dire toi et moi traditions et
savoir faire mon identité
la créativité raconte-moi son garde mon
patrimoine culturel immatériel mon
patrimoine vivant retrouvez nous sur
notre site internet
bonjour à tous merci de me retrouver sur
public sénat dans un instant vous allez
pouvoir suivre en direct l'audition de
cécile duflot la ministre du logement
elle est entendu par les sénateurs de la
commission des affaires économiques
sur le plan d'urgence en faveur du
bâtiment présenté la semaine dernière
par le gouvernement alors la principale
disposition est bien de ce plan
d'urgence et la mise en place d'une taxe
d'une prime exceptionnelle de 1350 euros
pour les ménages les plus modestes qui
rénovent leur logement alors sans plus
tarder direction est la salle clemenceau
pour écouter la ministre cécile duflot
bon après midi à tous éventuellement
désigné rapporteur qui intrigue beaucoup
pour le moment pourrait nommer mais que
je freine des quatre fers
j'espère d'ailleurs madame la ministre
que comme pour les derniers textes sur
le logement ce projet de loi pourrait
être discuté en priorité au sénat et ce
serait une marque de reconnaissance de
ce que nous avons vécu concernant la loi
duflot 1
merci madame la ministre vous avez seule
la parole monsieur le président d'abord
je vous remercie de m'accueillir je vous
remercie de votre invitation et de
l'attention vous portez à ces dossiers
vous avez raison d'évoquer le travail
que vous avez mené avec la ffb la capeb
ce secteur nécessite de la part de
l'ensemble de la puissance publique un
intérêt marqué est un secteur porteur
d'emplois durables non délocalisables et
c'est un secteur qui est aujourd'hui en
situation difficile et en même temps
c'est un secteur qui fait le lien avec
un sujet la question du logement qui est
un sujet décisif pour l'ensemble des
habitants de notre pays
nous avons déjà eu l'occasion ici de
faire le point sur la difficulté d'une
grande partie de la population regard du
logement entre ceux qui dans les zones
tendues ne peuvent pas avoir accès à un
logement de qualité ou avec un confort
normal du fait de leur composition
familiale du fait du coût des loyers qui
sur certaines régions de notre pays a
augmenté de manière extrêmement forte
ceux qui sont en situation de mal
logement liée à la qualité du logement à
la précarité énergétique de celui ci
voire même et depuis la conférence de
lutte contre la pauvreté et pour
l'inclusion sociale nous avons pris ce
dossier à bras le corps ce qu'ils sont
aujourd'hui en situation de nécessité
un hébergement je reprendrai pas devant
vous les chiffres de la construction ils
sont mauvais ils sont mauvais comme il
l'était l'année dernière je tiens à le
dire c'est une deuxième année
consécutive difficule difficile pour le
bâtiment il ne peut pas être dit par
quiconque eu la responsabilité incombe à
tel ou tel en matière de logement et de
construction les cycles sont souvent des
cycles durable une décision que nous
prendrions ici aura un impact c'est
certain à la fois à court terme et à
moyen terme mais l'on sait sur le long
terme que l'on vérifie l'efficacité
réelle de ces mesures et pour pouvoir
dire les choses les effets pervers de
certains dispositifs fiscaux n'ont été
vus qu'à moyen terme après la
construction et c'est aujourd'hui que
l'on constate sur certaines communes de
notre territoire des immeubles vides qui
pour leurs propriétaires donnent lieu à
une perte financière très importante qui
sont liées aux effets secondaires de
certains dispositifs la volonté du
gouvernement sur ce dossier c'est à la
fois de répondre à l'urgence est de
travailler aux réformes structurelles
vous avez donc opportunément rappelé
deux dossiers le plan d'investissement
sur le logement présentée par le
président de la république à alfortville
la semaine dernière et le projet de loi
que j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de vous
présenter ici comme une seconde étape
après la première loi que vous avez
effectivement fauté avec plaisir je
crois puisque
vous l'avez fait deux fois donc ce plan
d'urgence visent à déverrouiller un
certain nombre de dispositifs
simultanément pour donner le coup de
fouet nécessaire sur des questions sur
lesquelles pour certaines d'entre elles
tout le monde s'accorde à dire qu'elles
auront un effet immédiat à la fois sur
des questions normatives sur des
questions financières sur des questions
d' équilibre du parc
d'abord un premier volet du plan qui
vise à faciliter les projets urbains et
l'aménagement notamment par le
raccourcissement des délais de procédure
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de dire à quel
point le l'augmentation des délais de
traitement des recours sur les permis de
construire et les recours malveillants
de type quasiment mafieux puisque c'est
développés y compris de la part
d'anciens professionnels du secteur une
activité visant à racketter je pense que
les termes sont exactes ceux qui
déposent des permis de construire avec
des recours et en échange d'une d'un
abandon de celui ci qui est corrélée à
une somme d'argent des d'ailleurs des
personnes qui n'ont aucun lien et aucun
intérêt direct à agir sur le dépôt de
ces recours
donc il est très clair pour nous qu'il
faut à la fois raccourcir les délais des
traites de traitement des recours actuel
et dans le futur faciliter les
dispositions qui permettront notamment
sur les plus grosses opérations d'avoir
des délais de traitement plus rapide
ce sont aussi des dispositifs qui
peuvent sembler marginaux qui je le dis
seront très efficace notamment la
création du géoportail c'est à dire la
mise en ligne de tous les documents
d'urbanisme
aujourd'hui un architecte doit courir
dans certains cas les services de
l'urbanisme pour récupérer le pmu en
faire une photocopie à ses frais
laborieusement retrouver les horaires
d'ouverture la mise en ligne de tous les
documents d'urbanisme sera de nature
avec une cartographie qui l'a opéré qui
permettra un recoupement ce qu'on
appelle donc un géoportail sera de
nature à faciliter le travail de tous
les professionnels du secteur et ce très
rapidement
il faut en revanche une disposition
législative et pour faire en sorte que
ce dispositif fonctionne d'où l'intérêt
pour répondre en partie à votre première
question du recours aux ordonnances sur
un certain nombre de sujets il ne s'agit
pas de
forcer la main du parlement bien au
contraire il s'agit simplement sur des
dispositions sur lesquelles tout le
monde convient qu'elles seront assez
utile et efficace rapidement de gagner
entre 6 6 mois et 1 an dans leur mise en
oeuvre effective ce sont aussi les
dispositifs des dispositions plutôt
techniques notamment le taux maximal de
garantie d'emprunt pour les opérations
d'aménagement aujourd'hui avec le
renchérissement des critères qui sont
posés par les banques on voit qu'il ya
aussi un frein sur le lancement des
opérations nous amènerait sur un débat
sur les garanties prudentielles plus
important mais en tout cas il est
certain qu'un certain de ces dispositifs
permettront d'aller plus vite tout comme
il nous semble nécessaire comme je
l'avais dit à l'occasion de l'
abrogation de du dispositif des 30% que
le travail sur la densification continue
de se faire alors de se faire sur dans
le cadre du projet de loi et les choses
la suivent leur cours
mais aussi sur un sujet qui est un sujet
qui n'est pas marginale puisque rien
qu'en ile de france on comptait 3
millions de mètres carrés de bureaux
vides je veux parler de la
transformation des locaux de bureaux en
logements
ce sont des bâtiments déjà construits
mais qui pour certains d'entre eux se
trouvent sur des zones considérées comme
des zones d'activité au titre du pmu et
qui ne pourront être transformés en
logements qu'à l'issue d'une
modification de ce pays eut donc avec un
travail très long et des durées très
longues
il nous semble nécessaire de pouvoir
accélérer ces dispositifs en particulier
en zone tendue à proximité des à
proximité des transports en commun tout
comme les obligations de parking qui
pèsent sur les transformations
aujourd'hui si vous voulez transformer
un immeuble de bureaux sur sedan sur
certaines zones il faut créer deux
niveaux de sous-sols autant vous dire
que le budget qui peut y être allouée
est simplement impossible alors même
qu'on peut imaginer faire des petits
logements en particulier pour des jeunes
et y compris à proximité des transports
en commun ces opérations sont
aujourd'hui impossible à équilibrer
financièrement nous voulons aussi
sécuriser les opérations en vefa et
faciliter la gestion de la trésorerie
des entreprises du bâtiment par une
adaptation de la législation
ce sont des demandes pour lequel tout le
monde s'accorde à dire qu'elles sont
justifiées présentés par les entreprises
du secteur depuis de nombreuses années
auxquelles nous nous sommes que nous
pouvons donner droit très rapidement
pour faire face à la scie
la scion difficile nous souhaitons aussi
dans le cadre de la logique de mixité
dont je parle à chaque fois que je vous
parle de ses projets relatifs au
logement favoriser la mixité est donc
développé le statut du logement
intermédiaire ça permettra de répondre à
une partie du débat qui avait eu lieu
autour de la loi sur le logo tation du
plancher de logements sociaux de 2 25%
dans les communes concernées par la loi
sru en créant cette catégorie de
logements intermédiaires dans les plh
les collectivités locales pourront faire
en sorte d'insérer la nécessité de
construire ce type de logements
intermédiaires en le dotant d'un statut
on pourra éventuellement dans un
deuxième temps travailler à un
environnement législatives voire fiscale
qui permettra le développement de ce
maillon de la chaîne résidentiel
nécessaire celui de logements à un
niveau de loyer intermédiaire entre le
parc social et le parc locatif privé
il est absolument nécessaire dans une
période aussi difficile que le rôle
contracyclique des des bailleurs sociaux
prennent toute sa mesure pour ça nous
avons d'ores et déjà mobilisé un certain
nombre de dispositifs l'augmentation des
aides à la pierre
la mutualisation des des fonds propres
des différents organismes et également
la mobilisation d'action logement à
hauteur d'un milliard d'euros
supplémentaire de sumo d'équivalent
subventions qui seront délivrés en même
temps que les subventions d'état sur la
surcharge foncière c'est à dire avec une
automaticité
l'automaticité est une instruction de
dossiers très rapide c'était aussi ma
volonté que cette financement
complémentaire ne donnent pas lieu à des
tracasseries administratives
supplémentaires mais et le président de
la république en a fait l'annoncé dès le
1er janvier 2014 toutes les opérations
livrables à compter du 1er janvier donc
pas seulement celles qui seront déposés
mais livrables
de construction et de rénovation de
logements sociaux feront l'objet d'une
tva à 5%
l'objectif de ce choix en matière de
baisse de la tva c'est que du fait de
ces contraintes particulières et
notamment d'un niveau de loyer maximum
imposer la capacité du mouvement us âge
à construire davantage de logements
dépend du taux de consommation de fonds
propres opération par opération la
baisse du taux de tva un effet mécanique
immédiat sur la consommation des fonds
propres et donc là aussi mécanique et
mathématiques sur la possibilité pour
les organismes de construire davantage
je le dis de façon très simple
aujourd'hui nous sommes sur un fil de
l'eau à cent mille logements
vous savez que l'objectif du
gouvernement c'est 150 milles je crois
qu'avec tous les dispositifs dont je
viens de parler
les moyens existent cinquante mille
logements réalisés ces 85 mille emplois
directs et semis direct je ne compte
même pas les emplois indirects
dès l'année 2014 c'est donc un élément
absolument décisif puisque au delà de
l'engagement du gouvernement en faveur
de l'emploi
vous avez avec le plan d'investissement
logement une traduction concrète du
comment et des moyens que nous nous
donnons pour atteindre cet objectif
enfin sur la question foncière ou vous
savez qu'il était absolument nécessaire
d'agir
les décrets d'application de la loi
foncier public vont être publiés dans
les jours qui viennent
nous avons souhaité mais je crois que ça
faisait partie d'un certain nombre de
débats parlementaires créer un module
une gouvernance efficace de ce plan de
mobilisation je peux vous dire qu y
compris sur certains dossiers je les
suis personnellement pour que nous
habitent que nous aboutissions très
rapidement à des cession effective
il y aura également le président l'a dit
la fin des abattements pour durée de
détention pour le calcul des plus values
des terrains à bâtir des friches
commerciales et des logements
inhabitables
afin de lutter contre la rétention
foncière pour ce qui est de la
simplification de la vie des
professionnels je pense que vous avez
été sensibilisés aussi à cela par les
organismes professionnels
il a été décidé un moratoire sur les
normes nouvelles de techniques de
construction de 18 mois les
professionnels ont dit qu'effectivement
l'addition des normes
seesmic des normes de prévention
incendie les normes environnementales et
des normes handicap en quelques mois ont
été difficiles à additionner
simultanément nous avons donc décidé
qu'après sept ce moment normatif nous
aurions une pause et que les
professionnels pourraient donc
travailler sereinement sans sans aucun
risque en matière de qualité de
construction
nous avons aussi décidé de mettre en
place l'auto liquidation de la tva pour
ce qui est du grand chantier de la
rénovation énergétique dont vous avez
parlé monsieur le président sur lequel
nous avons effectivement travaillé avec
delphine batho il est très clair que
l'objectif du gouvernement est de tenir
les engagements pris par le président de
la république 500000 rénovation aux
parents 380000 dans le parc privé
cent vingt mille dans le parc social
notamment grâce à la tva à 5%
et pour cela de s'adresser directement
aux bénéficiaires de ce plan de
rénovation je veux parler des ménages
nous avons décidé de mettre en place
d'ouvrir les critères qui donne accès à
une subvention pour la réalisation de
ces travaux de rénovation thermique ce
seront désormais deux tiers des ménages
français qui seront concernés par cette
aide directe de 1350 euros et cumulables
évidemment avec le ses idées des jeux
rappelle que le crédit impôt
développement durable mise en place en
2005 par le précédent gouvernement et je
le dis parce que il faut dire les choses
et dispositifs qui a montré son
efficacité notamment du fait de son
statut de crédit d'impôt qui permet un
remboursement aux personnes qui ne
payent pas d'impôts et pas seulement une
déduction à ceux qui en payent ce crédit
d'impôt va être redimensionnés il sera
évidemment lui aussi cumulable avec
l'éco ptz éco ptz que nous voulons voir
certifier par les entreprises certifiées
grenelle pour que nous soyons en
situation de pouvoir débloquer des
dossiers qui sont aujourd'hui bloqués à
l'instruction dans les banques
nous mettrons évidemment en place mais
ça je vous l'avais déjà dit un guichet
unique et un numéro vert pour simplifier
l'accès à ce dispositif aujourd'hui il
faut parfois s'adressait à trois quatre
cinq intervenants pour pouvoir avoir
l'ensemble des informations et surtout
parce que la question de la lutte contre
la précarité énergétique
est une des priorités du gouvernement
nous avons j'ai signé avec l'anah une
convention pour le recrutement de 1000
ambassadeur de la rénovation énergétique
au titre des emplois d'avenir et du
service civique
ces ambassadeurs auront pour mission
d'aller au-devant des ménages victimes
de précarité énergétique qui ne sont pas
forcément ceux qui se signalent le plus
je veux en particulier penser aux
personnes âgées qui sont isolés qui sont
dans des logements dont ils sont
propriétaires et qu'ils pensent qu'ils
pensent souvent ne pas avoir de droit à
ce type de dispositifs ou qui sont
craintifs du démarchage par certains
professionnels dont certains qui ont
tablé sur certains dispositifs
précédemment l'ont fait avec peu de
légèreté voire peu de professionnalisme
donc ces ambassadeurs de la rénovation
énergétique auront cette mission de
lutter contre la précarité énergétique
et pourront s'appuyer sur un dispositif
renforcé pour les personnes les plus
modestes en situation de précarité
énergétique qui elles bénéficieront d'un
montant de subvention de 3000 euros pour
les travaux réalisés
je crois avoir fait le tour de
l'ensemble du dossier
en vous disant que la volonté donc du
gouvernement c'est bien de répondre à
l'urgence de façon cohérente avec la
réforme de structure sur laquelle nous
travaillons mais de ne pas faire
abstraction de ce travail sur le projet
de loi puisque nous travaillerons
également sur les questions de règles
d'urbanisme d'articulation entre les
différents niveaux de schémas des
niveaux régionaux op est lui qui auront
vocation à devenir des p lus
intercommunaux travailler sur les
questions de copropriété du rôle des
syndics et les professionnels de
l'immobilier bref toutes les questions
que nous avions déjà eu l'occasion de
présenter et de discuter ensemble mais
sur lesquelles nous reviendrons sans
doute pour répondre très précisément à
votre élément à votre question sur le
calendrier le la nécessité de faire des
ordonnances est apparu pour des
questions de délais et de
raccourcissement des délais vous
connaissez mieux que moi
la tension sur le calendrier
parlementaire le projet de loi à lui
pour objectif d'être adopté avant le le
la fin du mois de juin et donc son sa
présentation est salée sa première
lecture pour lequel il n'est pas arrêté
que ce soit à l'assemblée nationale ou
au sénat mais ce trailer
ce serait avec plaisir que je viendrais
devant vous j'ai toujours passé de
grands moments de débats parlementaires
au sénat avec alma un très grand plaisir
monsieur le président donc je rentrais
je ne ferai pas partie de ceux qui parmi
mes collègues ça existe qui ne souhaite
pas venir vous voir des premiers on
considère que c'est plus difficile pas
pour pas pour moi du tout mais je vous
dis les dates ne sont pas arrêtés
notamment parce qu'il y à la réunion du
congrès et l'impact sur le calendrier
parlementaire
en revanche pour ce qui est du projet de
loi d'habilitation non je tiens à leur
dire il ne s'agit pas d'avoir un débat
on peut évidemment avoir un débat
principe yele théorique sur les
ordonnances comme vous le savez dans le
cadre de la constitution de la vème
république les ordonnances sont très
sévèrement contrôlés par les
parlementaires que vous êtes le projet
de loi d'habilitation sera détaillée sur
sur le sur le le contour des
dispositions qui pourront être adoptés
l'objectif ça n'est absolument pas de
contourner qui que ce soit au contraire
c'est sur des questions qui sur lesquels
nous avons avancé je peux dire
d'ailleurs sur des questions sur
lesquelles la précédente majorité
avaient avancé nous puissions faire en
sorte qu'elle soit mise en oeuvre plus
rapidement pour répondre à une situation
d'urgence dans le secteur l'idée donc il
fasse et que le projet de loi
d'habilitation à ce stade soit présenté
le 17 avril au conseil des ministres
pour la date exacte d'examen à
l'assemblée nationale ou au sénat à ce
stade je ne peux pas vous la dire avec
certitude mais vous avez compris que ce
sera le plus rapidement possible
évidemment vous avez compris madame la
ministre que c'est un domaine qui
intéresse tout particulièrement les
collectivités concernant tous les
problèmes de logement d'urbanisme se
sont bien fait a priori le sénat qui est
le premier concerné parce que d'après la
constitution qui censé représenter les
collectivités les territoires et donc
voilà je répète mon invitation pressante
peut-être madame la ministre mais je
chanterai part au ministère des
relations tendues à log avec le pression
live public sur il prévenu ni sur ces
questions via la parole est un monsieur
claude berri de bla oui merci monsieur
le président moi je voudrais d'abord
saluer les mesures annoncées jeudi par
le président de la république c'est un
véritable plan d'urgence ce qui était
attendu par les professionnels du
bâtiment et quand nous avions rencontré
ensemble à la fois le président de la
capeb et le président de la fédération
française du bâtiment
il nous avait demandé nous avait attiré
notre attention sur l'urgence de ces
mesures attendues ces faits dont je me
félicite de ces mesures
je voudrais également saluer
l'implication très forte à la fois du
président de la république du
gouvernement et de vous-mêmes madame la
ministre que je félicite puisque après
une série de mesures le premier qui
était qui était notamment dans la loi la
première loi du feu dont j'étais le
rapporteur avec la la mise à disposition
du foncier après l'encadrement des
loyers
après
je dirais une des mesures d'incitation à
la construction après le relèvement du
livret a on arrive aujourd'hui à des
mesures qui sont importantes et qui sont
importantes à mes yeux à deux niveaux
d'abord sur le plan économique parce que
ça va permettre de booster de relancer
l'activité du bâtiment
et puis au niveau social puisque en fait
ça va créer du logement social qui est
une demande très forte de haut niveau de
nos concitoyens sur les mesures et le
même vous les avez détails et je
voudrais simplement mettre l'accent sur
la baisse du taux de la tva vous l'avez
dit vous-même cette baisse du taux de la
tva à 5%
c'est une baisse due tu sais jamais été
à ce niveau là l'ancien gouvernement l'a
mené à cette lave est monté à 7 %
comme vous l'a dit mécaniquement c'est
une auto financement parlement de 6000
euros
et ça représente comme l'avait dit à peu
près 22500 de mémoire logement qui
pourrait être produit mécaniquement par
cette mesure fiscale
c'est une mesure qui était attendu je
vous le rappelle mes chers collègues par
l'ensemble des gens que nous avons
rencontrés et nous avions nous étions
notamment engagées au niveau de cette
commission a plaidé pour que l'on puisse
baisser le taux de tva c'est important
certains le voulait pour tous nous
l'avons fait pour le plan social dont je
me félicite je passe ici l'action que
nous avons menée est déterminante mais
elle a dû permettre d'arriver à ce
résultat
je ne
je n'évoquerai pas le plan de
réformation le de rénovation énergétique
vous en avez parlé aussi je pense que
c'est très très important les 1350 euros
pour des ménages une moyens ils sont
bien entendu pro faune et à un niveau de
ressources me semble en plus du
dispositif que vous avez pris fier me
semble très bon dispositif pour relancer
également le secteur du bâtiment
donc voilà dont je salue les efforts et
le travail que vous avez mises en place
je voudrais vous proposez vous posé par
deux vendeuses de questions en plus de
celles qui ont été posées par notre
président éminemment prééminent
président la première concerne la
publication des décrets concernant les
décotes la décote puisque en tant que
rapporteur rappelez-vous nous étions
battus pour inverser un peu vous voulez
qu'on parte 2-0 les terrains est donnée
gratuitement l'avons eu l'effet inverse
mais je voudrais savoir quand c'est que
ça va rentrer en vigueur et surtout
quand c'est que nous allons connaître la
liste des terrains sur lequel nous
allons pouvoir travailler ça nous sommes
très important et la deuxième question
concerne le pacte avec l'union sociale
pour l'habitat nous allons recevoir de
mr le président quel est le contour exa
de ce pacte et quelle est la mise en
application de ce pacte dont deux
questions toutes simples mais qui
peuvent nous éclairer sur les efforts
supplémentaires à faire en matière du
logement social merci
et encore vous dites j'ai même que ces
deux questions simples afin de mettra
peut-être un peu plus de temps madame la
mûre oui merci président madame la
ministre dans les dispositifs efficaces
en faveur du logement locatif il y avait
le dispositif scellier qui a donc pris
fin au mois de décembre
vous y avez substitué le vôtre que je ne
critique absolument pas mais je
m'interroge sur la raison qui vous a
conduit à ne pas faire cohabiter au
moins pendant une période les deux
dispositifs
ça aurait sans doute évité cette espèce
de trou d'air que ressentent aujourd'hui
les professionnels de la construction en
matière de logement donc c'est quelque
chose qui a eu lieu par le passé
je crois savoir que les dispositifs qui
laisse et méhaignerie avait été maintenu
pendant une période de un an ou deux ans
et que presque deux ans et que donc
c'était ça avait été un bienfait ensuite
concernant le financement du
du logement hlm est-ce que vous
n'envisagez pas de dispositions qui
pourraient permettre de dégager des
financements pour pour les constructions
nouvelles et qui pourrait être une
décote mais une décote importante sur
les ventes de logements hlm aux
propriétaires occupants est-ce qu'il
permettrait de cette manière de dégager
des financements pour les nouvelles
opérations
et puis enfin concernant la tva
donc là nous avons bien noté la baisse
de la tva à 5%
mais les professionnels du bâtiment et
plus particulièrement les professions
artisanales sont inquiètes de l'arrivée
de la tva à 10% à partir de 2 janvier
prochain sur les travaux de rénovation
et on sait bien que lorsque nous avions
assisté au passage de 19,6 à 5,5
mais immédiatement il y a eu un rebond
d'activité dans ces professions et les
mêmes espérait bien à nouveau les mêmes
effets dans la mesure où la tva serait
maintenu à cinq et demi ou à 7 comme
actuellement et que pensez-vous faire
dans ce domaine là je vous remercie
qui je vous signale que vous êtes à peu
près 10 à l'heure actuelle a demandé la
parole
donc je vous demanderais si possible
d'être concis ce qui pourrait changer
pour les gens de toulouse par exemple
mais madame mireille cherche
merci monsieur le président les
bourbonnais sont toujours très concis
merci madame la ministre pour cet exposé
clair rapide mais nous saluons un grand
nombre de ces mesures
j'ai neuf questions à vous poser la
création mais je vais aller vite
la création d'un géoportail de
l'urbanisme par numérisation dont vous
avez pas parlé c'est une bonne mesure
qui va la payer
deuxième question vous avez parlé de
transformer les bureaux en logements et
donc des bureaux vacants où en est la
réflexion sur la vacance
vous nous aviez dit que c'était une
question qui bloquait l'instauration
d'une taxe sur les bureaux vacants entre
autres où on est cette question alors la
tva bien sûr à 5% ne sera que pour la
rénovation thermique des logements
sociaux et leur construction nous le
regrettons et l'unité sans doute plus
enfin plus un peu plus favorable pour
ces constructions de deux d'un de
rajouter la réhabilitation parce que ça
va être compliqué d'ailleurs de faire la
différence entre réhabilitation
rénovation thermique
c'est tout alors la réhabilitation fois
parti alors vous allez nous préciser ce
point
et puis écouter la tva à 7% pour tout le
reste sans doute que les professionnels
l'attendait
quatrième question aller à 10 oui c'est
ça pourquoi ne je vais trouver pourquoi
ne pas avoir instauré comme nous
l'avions proposé un prêt à taux zéro
pour les offices hlm qui à mon avis
serait une bonne mesure
cinquième question vous avez parlé du
coût du foncier et lutter contre la
rétention foncière dites vous
nous avons beaucoup et vous le savez
fait des propositions sur le foncier et
nous avions parlé d'un rapport sur la
possibilité d'un mécanisme d'encadrement
de la valeur du foncier ce que vous
pouvez me dire si vous avez progressé
sur ce sur cette idée qui me paraît qui
nous paraît bien sûr extrêmement
important mais vous aussi d'ailleurs
pour la maîtrise du coût du foncier nous
avions aussi fait la proposition
suivante lorsqu'il ya un projet
d'aménagement que le coût du foncier
soit stoppée au début de ce projet
d'aménagement puisqu'en général c'est
des effets d'aubaine qui permettent à
tout le foncier environnants d'augmenter
considérablement
vous parlez des ambassadeurs et d'un
guichet unique nous sommes favorables
bien sûr à ce guichet unique tout le
monde le constate il peut être financier
peut être aussi technique parce que les
personnes qui s'engagent dans la
rénovation thermique ont besoin d' aide
pour le financement de leurs projets
mais aussi technique et on a remarqué
que entre les diagnostics les artisans
et il y avait beaucoup de confusion et
qu'elles seront quel sera le statut de
ces ambassadeurs dans quel cadre seront
utiles dans les espaces info énergie
dans l' ademe je ne sais pas ensuite la
dernière question je crois non oui
non pour les expulsions locatives vous
avez parlé d'un moratoire jusqu'au 1er
avril
nous considérons pour skill notre part
de continuer ce moratoire au delà du 1er
avril temps c'est humainement compliqué
ces expulsions
à condition de prévoir sans doute une
indemnisation pour les propriétaires
voilà madame la ministre
merci concernant le foncier ce serait
bien mal à mener min si je veux être
directif qu'on comprenne bien quelles
sont les projets et en particulier
d'aversion d'une femme à fiscalité
c'est quelque chose qui est dans l'air
je sais mais je sais pas si ses murs
autrement dit plus vous retenez inde
à l'heure actuelle un foncier moins vous
payez il faudrait inverser la
proposition ou alors prendre la solution
nordiques qui consiste à taxer sur les
valeurs vénales
non c'est pas madame la maire monsieur
calvet non mais tu vois la tension que
je te porte dit monsieur le président si
et ne rougissez pas madame monsieur
calvet sur le président je voudrais
d'abord m'associer aux deux questions
que vous avez posé au départ parce que
je pense que le sénat mérite
effectivement que ce débat-là soit en
premier dans notre dans notre hémicycle
je voudrais aussi rappeler que ce plan
d'urgence arrive quelques semaines
seulement après le vote d'une loi sur le
logement dont vous nous aviez annoncé
qu'elle devait assurer la construction
de 5000 logements par an dont 150
logements
cent cinquante mille logements sociaux
je m'étais d'ailleurs efforcé
d'expliquer sans succès que vous ne
pourriez pas malheureusement atteindre
cet objectif car les collectivités
locales ne peuvent plus emprunter à des
toiles acceptable pour boucler leurs
opérations et que les opérateurs privés
connaissent des difficultés pour
réaliser leurs objectifs ce plan
d'urgence en un moins le mérite
d'exister et je constate que vous tentez
de répondre à plusieurs préoccupations
que nous avions formulées lors du débat
tenter d'endiguer la multiplication des
recours
la suppression programmée des
incitations fiscales à la rétention de
terrains et la plus importante peut-être
nous instituer un moratoire sur les
normes pour deux ans que ça c'est très
important et je vois toutefois deux
objections majeures au succès de ce plan
le temps de la construction n'est pas
celui de la communication et la relance
de la machine ne se fera pas tant que la
crise persistera
vous ne réglerez pas le premier problème
du logement qui est celui de son
financement
je reviendrai tout leur demi questions
et les opérateurs publics peinent à
boucler leurs emprunts et les personnes
privées ne peuvent plus important à mon
compte et malgré les trop très bas alors
le gouvernement du royaume uni j'ai lu
dans les échos du 22 mars dernier
s'apprête à garantir 133 milliards de
livres de prêts immobiliers pour
relancer la filière et à mon avis c'est
une mesure qui va fonctionner alors je
précise que cette solution anglaise est
sans impact sur le déficit public et la
dette et donc peut-être qu'on pourrait
essayer de regarder cette question
le plan que vous proposez lui se
contente de réserve et 400 millions des
400 millions d'euros d'efforts publics
aux seuls hlm à travers la baisse de la
tva dont j'y reviendrai tout à l'heure
c'est une bonne chose mais cela ne règle
pas la question devient son opération et
j'ai donc deux questions la première
j'avais attiré votre attention à deux
reprises lors du débat du 9 novembre et
du 17 décembre sur le problème des
garanties d'emprunt nécessaires aux
opérateurs hlm pour accéder au crédit de
la caisse au crédit de la caisse des
dépôts et des autres banques
ces garanties d'emprunt données par les
collectivités sont de plus en plus
difficiles à obtenir
pourquoi parce que dans les organismes
de notation elles mêmes
ils sont maintenant de plus en plus
comptabilisés comme une vraie dette
comme l'encours de dette quand les
collectivités emprunté beaucoup de
collectivités dans notre région déjà ont
baissé leurs taux de garantie d'emprunt
et donc c'est une mesure qui me paraît
moins importante les garanties d'emprunt
l'argent qu'ils aient pris les prix du
livret a et l'état garantit le livret a
je ne vois pas pourquoi on impose de
garantir deux fois la même la même chose
je pense que là il ya un point vous le
verrez on va le rencontrer dans les mois
qui viennent nous mêmes à la communauté
d'agglomération de perpignan
nous avons dû baisser le taux de
garantie et les collectivités qui sur
lesquels se font les programmes sont
intervenus un peu plus fortement
sauf que par exemple pour ma commune
je donne cours de cette méthode de 8
millions d'euros le seul programme que
je fais pour essayer de remonter à même
pour ça il est déjà de 13 millions
d'euros et jean garantie 60 pour ça donc
et la communauté 40
donc vous voyez les de suite les
difficultés dès que c'est cette
comptabilité etc
ceci est comptabilisé dans les rations
là je pense qu'il ya un problème sur les
garanties d'emprunt que jeu sur lequel
je voudrais attirer votre attention et
savoir comment vous comptez répondre à
cette question la deuxième question
c'est sur les conditions d'application
de la bande qui est prévu par la loi du
18 janvier 2013 en cas de carence des
communes
il semble en effet que les services de
l'état est envoyé un certain nombre de
calculs qui vont dans le sens d'ajouter
pour faire le constat de carence un
objectif de production de logements pour
les trois derniers trimestres de 2013 en
plus du critère de réalisation de
l'objectif triennal sur la période
2011-2013 pour les pl lâche l'objectif
de l'emmener 2013 serait fixé à 1 12e de
l'objectif triennal a réalisé sur les
trois derniers trimestres de 2013 cet
objectif doit il être entendu comme
faisant partie intégrante de l'objectif
triennal 2011 2013
où en est il un objectif spécifique et
dons supplémentaires selon les
informations transmises par les services
de l'état
elle est appréciera au titre de l'année
ventes ul constat de carence le niveau
atteint l'objectif global sur les trois
ans 2011-2013 et le niveau atteint de
l'objectif spécifique de 2013
a priori les communes qui n'atteignent
pas les deux objectifs verront leurs
pénalités majoré par cinq
vous pouvez vous me dire si cela est
exact j'ajoute que vous avez précisé
alors j'ai pris moi la conférence de
presse je termine
on a parlé de la baisse de la tva enfin
le retour de la tva à 5%
ça c'était quelque chose qui est
dispensable collègues mary débat ça
n'est fait le vôtre mais bon c'est un
point très important sauf que dans la
conférence de presse et des organismes
hlm que j'ai réuni la semaine dernière
j'ai senti que n'était pas pressé de
construire parce qu'ils ont compris eux
que la tva à 5% ce serait à partir du
1er janvier 2014
jeudi eux parce que vous avez dit vous
par rapport aux vous avez vous avez
ajouté
tout à l'heure dans votre exposé
livrables donc ça il faut vite le
préciser parce que dans votre papier de
conférence de presse dans le communiqué
saniez pas de merci madame la ministre
après d'abord les neuf questions de
madame cherche et les nombres de
questions que vient de lire notre
collègue qu'elle veut je pense qu'il
vaut mieux que vous commenciez par
répondre là parce que alors d'abord pour
répondre à monsieur bérit-debat sur la
publication des décrets pour le premier
décret qui va être publié à la fin du
mois de mars dans les tout prochains
jours
c'est le décret sur le foncier public
d'état puis viendra le décret sur les
établissements publics puis celui sur
les établissements publics de santé
donc d'ici au plus tard à la fin du mois
de mai puisque sur l'établissement
depuis de santé il ya davantage de
débats interministériel l'ensemble des
décrets seront publiés voilà pour vous
apporter la réponse donc nous imaginons
pouvoir signer les premières sessions
appuyé sur la loi dans les dans les
prochains jours en sachant qu'il a déjà
été envoyé une circulaire d'explication
et d'interprétation au préfet pour
pouvoir instruire les dossiers en lien
avec les collectivités locales pour ce
qui est de la liste le choix qui a été
fait et d'arrêter une liste au niveau
départemental east géré par les préfets
puisque là
la centralisation avait donné lieu à des
imperfections pour ne pas venir
davantage donc je souhaite que les
choses soient gérés très directement
avec les collectivités locales ce qui
nous permet aussi d'intervenir au niveau
de l'ue ministériel comme une forme de
recours dans le cas où les collectivités
identifie des terrains qui ne font pas
partie de la liste établie par le préfet
mais qui les intéressent pour élaborer
un projet pour ce qui est du pacte avec
lui s h l'objectif est de construire un
pacte d'ici le milieu du mois de mai
j'espère les choses avancent bien au
conçu autour de trois volets un volet
patrimonial un volet social et un volet
pilotage un volet patrimonial qui notent
bien les engagements respectifs de
l'état mais maintenant ils sont connus
et celui du monde hlm pour réaliser la
production de logements neufs conformes
aux engagements du président de la
république et de répondre aux défis du
développement durable notamment par la
rénovation thermique mais pas
exclusivement madame cherche donc la tva
à 5% c'est l'ensemble des travaux
réalisés par les organismes de logement
social
donc que ce soit des travaux de
rénovation thermique ou des travaux de
rénovation plus globale évidemment de
réhabilitation où les travaux de
construction le volet social avec un
volet pour favoriser l'accueil des plus
démunis et notamment des personnes
hébergées ou des prioritaires dalo il y
a un vrai sujet de perméabilité entre le
secteur de l'hébergement et le secteur
du logement social notamment avec des
engagements en matière d'accompagnement
qui peuvent être faits par les
structures d'hébergement initial mais il
faut absolument que ce cet objectif du
logement d'abord soient mises en oeuvre
par une meilleure implication des
bailleurs sociaux territoire par
territoire de deuxièmement un point qui
me tient particulièrement à coeur et sur
lequel nous travaillons avec la ministre
vallaud belkacem qui est d'avoir une
offre spécifique de logements à
destination des femmes victimes de
violences il s'agit donc là de logements
équipés et meublés pour permettre
l'accueil en urgence de ces femmes qui
n'ont d'autre difficulté que celle de
devoir fuir et parfois même avec leurs
enfants le domicile conjugal donc il y
aura un engagement des partenaires du
monde hlm pour pouvoir développer cette
offre dans leur parc
et enfin d'adapter les loyers au service
rendu et aux besoins de logement des
plus défavorisés avec le développement
d'une offre spécifique
il faut nous travaillerons également
également sur l'amélioration du service
rendu aux locataires il y a toujours des
questions qui se posent dans les
relations entre les bailleurs et
locataires et enfin le troisième volet
c'est un volet relatif au pilotage avec
l'amélioration de la coopération entre
organismes
la question de la mutualisation des
fonds propres est un des sujets mais
normalement elle a déjà fait l'objet
d'un engagement pris par jeu pas quel
est le terme exact le comité exécutif de
l'ue et sache une renégociation de
certains objectifs des conventions
d'utilité sociale qui méritent d'être
revus après quelques années d'exercice
et enfin le suivi de la mise en oeuvre
des engagements du pacte puisque comme
vous l'avez noté il ne s'agit pas d'un
exercice abstrait mais bien
d'engagements concrets pris de part et
d'autre qui ont vocation à être non
seulement réaliser mais vérifier dans la
réalisation
mois après mois madame lamure la
cohabitation entre le dispositif
scellier le nouveau dispositif a existé
pendant trois mois justement pour
permettre le tuilage en sachant que si
nous avons décidé de mettre en place un
nouveau dispositif c'est bien au vu des
lacunes et des insuffisances du
dispositif scellier et de son coût pour
un service rendu qui pouvait être revu
je dois pouvoir vous dire quelques mois
après la mise en marche du dispositif
que les peaux l'ensemble des
professionnels après évidemment les
hésitations initiales commence à voir
l'intérêt de ce dispositif d'autant
qu'il a été ouvert et je tiens le
signaler au patrimoine ancien rénové
avec travaux d'importantes donc c'est un
dispositif qui permet la construction
neuve mais qui permet aussi de remettre
sur le marché du patrimoine ancien en
centre ville sur la question de la vente
du secteur hlm
je tiens à dire que sur cette question
il est absolument regrettable de
considérer que la vente du parc est
uniquement une doit se poser uniquement
en terme de rentrées financières pour
les organismes et que donc cela se peut
se substituer à d'autres dispositifs
pourquoi parce que dans un moment où
nous devons tous nous devons faire face
dans certaines zones géographiques
je pense en particulier au sud de la
france avec des copropriétés des années
80 qui commence à donner des signes
sérieux d'inquiétude au titre
de l'appréhension des copropriétés
dégradées on peut notamment pour des
immeubles qui ne sont pas rénovés se
retrouver en situation de fabriquer nous
avons déjà quelques quelques signes
d'inquiétude des prêts copropriété
dégradée parce que les locataires qui
achètent n'ont pas les moyens de faire
face à des dépenses très importantes sur
des immeubles qui sont des immeubles des
années 60 et 70 qui sont des passoires
thermiques donc je pense qu'il est
vraiment il peut être préjudiciable de
mettre un certain nombre de familles
dans cette situation là en sachant par
par ailleurs que forcément la volonté de
se retourner vers le bailleur qui reste
propriétaire d'une partie des logements
est tentante que du coup les situations
sont parfois extrêmement compliqué enfin
pour ce qui est de la tva pour le reste
du secteur du bâtiment et en particulier
les travaux de rénovation thermique ce
sujet sera évoluer évalué et discuté
dans le cadre du groupe de travail qui a
vocation à réfléchir sur l'application
des nouveaux taux de tva qui a été
décidé par les travaux du parlement est
le choix qui a été fait je le redis en
matière de rénovation unique et de
rénovation thermique c'est d'aller en
direction des ménages
quand on fait le choix d'une tva à 5%
l'évaluation qui en est fait une
évaluation qui impacte sur moins de
10000 rénovation supplémentaires alors
que cette prime qui est d'un montant
significatif aura sans doute un impact
pour déclencher plus de 100000
rénovation dès 2014
et ça c'est un élément décisif pour
atteindre un objectif l'objectif des 500
milles rénovation par an c'est aussi
très directement à destination des
ménages c'est à dire que cette prime est
mise en oeuvre dès les semaines qui
viennent et elle sera à destination
immédiate des ménages et nous n'aurons
pas à attendre le 1er janvier 2014 donc
c'est bien un dispositif le
dimensionnement du dispositif de
rénovation thermique a été choisi et en
direction des ménages et facilite le
déclenchement de travaux de manière très
rapide paraît effectivement une réalité
c'est que ce plan est décidée pour les
deux prochaines années
il est très incitatif il est il sera
très utile pour avoir des débouchés
d'activités pour les professionnels mais
aussi pour avoir un impact sur les
factures de chauffage qui augmente dans
un certain nombre de logements
malam cherche pour ce qui est
du géoportail le dispositif sera mis en
place sous l'égide de l'état puisqu'il
s'agit d'un dispositif qui doit être
partagé par tous ensuite ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est qu'aujourd'hui la
numérisation des documents par les
collectivités existe il existe
simplement elle n'est pas interfacé avec
le dispositif national donc il ne s'agit
pas d'un coup supplémentaire à part
quelques rares exceptions nous avons un
problème technique a levé qui est de
choisir le référentiel du cadastre ou le
référentiel de l'hygiène pour vous
répondre de façon très précise mais
c'est la seule difficulté que nous avons
à lever ensuite il s'est jamais dit que
c'est simplement un peu une décision et
d'imprimer une volonté de lever cet
obstacle technique mais ça n'est pas une
question de coûts majeurs puisque ces
documents existent et a dit à part
quelques rares exceptions notamment pour
les communes qui n'ont aujourd'hui que
des cartes communales
les documents sont déjà numérisées pour
la transformation des bureaux en
logements la question qui nous avaient
occupé dans le débat était la question
de l'identification de la vacance des
immeubles de bureaux nous ne sommes pas
au bout de ce travail
pour l'instant il est extrêmement
difficile je le dis de pouvoir
identifier de façon très précise des
bureaux vacants vous la réflexion à
l'époque était plutôt sur la taxation de
ce si peu sur leur transformation en
logements donc nous avons choisi des
dispositifs qui seront incitatif
notamment je pense aux bailleurs sociaux
pour pouvoir acquérir ces immeubles et
les transformer en logements il faut
savoir que pour certains d'entre eux je
pense en particulier aux bureaux des
années 70 80 qui sont des bureaux qui
n'ont pas des immenses plateaux qui ont
beaucoup d'éclairage naturel qui sont
plus faciles à transformer en bureaux en
logements pardon qui n'ont en revanche
pas de parking en sous sol et qui sont
très coûteux à mettre aux normes de
bureaux actuels se sait le patrimoine
que nous visons pour pour sa
transformation aujourd'hui un certain
nombre d'investisseurs les conserves en
attendant les des possibilités
d'investissement donc nous travaillerons
en parallèle dans le cadre de la future
loi sur cette question de la taxation
des bureaux vacants
toutes les propositions et y compris
celles que pour vous pourrez faire bien
sûr seront les bienvenus parce que nous
nous n'avons aujourd'hui par les clefs
précise qui nous permette comme pour la
taxe d'habitation sur les immeubles de
logements de pouvoir les identifier
j'ai répondu sur la tva sur le secteur
du logement social qui coûtent bien
l'ensemble du secteur pour ce qui est du
prêt à taux zéro l'écho pls le président
de la république l'a annoncé aura un
taux de 1% c'est un taux extrêmement
incitatif on peut difficilement faire
mieux je peux vous dire que pour les
faits du secteur il ya un laïc doit y
avoir dans le secteur et les engagements
devant être pris et tenue dans le cadre
du pacte avec lui et sache pour ses
travaux de rénovation qui là aussi on
aura un impact très direct sur
l'activité du secteur mais aussi sur les
locataires puisque ce sont des bâtiments
dans lequel les baisses de charges
peuvent être extrêmement importante et
rapide sur le la question du mécanisme
d'encadrement du du coût du foncier il
la lettre de mission que j'ai signé pour
le cgedd et donc pour qu'il y ait un
rapport effectué par des membres du
cgedd et à ma signature
et donc elle sera envoyée au cg cgedd
dans les jours qui viennent et donc ce
rapport commencera à être préparée par
le cgedd qui est la bonne le bon
organisme pour mener à bien ses travaux
sur le guichet unique vous l'avais dit
je pense que c'est absolument décisif le
vrai sujet en fait c'est vraiment la
mobilisation de tous sur cette question
de rénovation thermique c'est à dire sur
un changement de de réflexion de
pratiquer sur cette conviction partagée
que on peut vraiment avoir une
efficacité énergétique très importante
part des travaux à la fois d'isolation
de changement des appareils voire même
d'efficacité énergétique active je veux
donner deux exemples très concrets
un exemple qui est celui d'une maison de
deux maisons d'ailleurs des années 60
quasiment identique des maisons sur deux
mis sous sol que vous avez tous vu assez
carrée avec un toit à quatre pentes peut
isoler la même maison 4500 euros de
chauffage au fuel 2000 euros avec une
isolation une pompe à chaleur est un
show un chauffe-eau thermodynamique
c'est à dire 200 euros d'économie par
mois pour la famille qui habite un autre
exemple exactement même type de logement
unis en mai
on 200 m² dont l'extension réalisée fait
50 mètres carrés baisse donc extension
de 50 m² et baisse du coût de chauffage
avec le changement simplement de la
chaudière de 30%
voilà la réalité aujourd'hui de
l'efficacité que l'on peut avoir c'est à
dire d'une efficacité sonnantes et
trébuchantes dans un moment où la crise
rend parfois la situation sociale des
familles de notre pays encore plus
difficile nous pouvons la avancer de
manière extrêmement résolue pour faire
baisser les factures dans le budget des
ménages avec avec là pour le coup on est
sur un investissement autour de 15 à 17
milles euros sur sur les travaux
d'efficacité énergétique
évidemment sur coûts de construction
dans mon souvenir on doit être à 1200
euros au mètre carré pour l'extension
sur les expulsions locatives donc la
réponse du gouvernement a été la
prolongation pour l'instant de 15 jours
de la trêve hivernale a été une autre
réponse qui était de signer le 26
octobre avec mon collègue manuel valls
une circulaire qui ne rend pas possible
recours à la force publique pour
l'expulsion des personnes en situation
reconnues prioritaires au titre de la
loi dalo ce qui est important puisqu'il
y avait une forme de contradiction à
expulser des ménages reconnus
prioritaires au titre de la loi
parallèlement nous travaillons sur la
garantie universelle des loyers la
garantie universelle des loyers aura
trois objectifs le premier celui de
faciliter l'accès au logement en levant
les obstacles à l'accès je pense en
particulier aux jeunes le deuxième de
sécuriser les propriétaires tous les
propriétaires et en particulier tous
ceux qui sont loin de leur logement qui
ne possède qu'un seul logement et pour
qui la location et la mise en location
était une source de complexité et aussi
de tracasseries dans l'hypothèse d'un
impayé donc les propriétaires pourront
recevoir de la part de cette garantie le
paiement de leur loyer dès le premier
mois d'impayés et par voie de
conséquence ce signalement dès le
premier mois d'impayés permettra une
identification très précoce
d'éventuelles difficultés sociales et
donc de l'intervention en amont pour
pouvoir éviter les expulsions locatives
on sait très bien que les filets de
sécurité
les dispositifs
le fsl les dispositifs d'accès au
logement social existe simplement ils ne
sont des fois pas activée au moment où
c'est nécessaire parce que ces familles
enfoncé dans la difficulté et hésitent à
appeler ou à demander de l'aide
elles seront du fait de la garantie
identifier très en amont et nous
pourrons intervenir donc très en amont
monsieur qu'elle veut je ne crois pas
avoir dit que la loi que vous avez voté
aurait pour objectif immédiat la
création la construction de cinq cent
mille logements je suis parfois très
optimiste mais assez raisonnable dans le
fond sur ce que j'annonce en revanche ça
y contribue parce que la cession du
foncier public et ce dès cette année
permettra justement la construction d'un
certain nombre de projets qui intègrent
de logement social mais pas seulement
sur la question de la situation anglaise
moi aussi je suis sensible à ce qui a
été fait sur la garantie des emprunts je
dois vous dire qu'aujourd'hui la
situation française n'est moins une
situation de problèmes de garantie des
emprunts qu'une question de prix de
l'immobilier qu'une question d'accès au
crédit pour des ménages très particulier
je pense aux femmes seules ou aux
familles monoparentales qui font l'objet
aujourd'hui d'une situation plus
délicate
donc il me semble pas que c'est la bonne
clé a utilisé aujourd'hui pour débloquer
ce secteur je tiens à signaler et je
pense d'eux sans aucun esprit polémique
que là les crédits d'impôts des
empreintes d'une partie des emprunts sur
l'acquisition de la résidence principale
ont participé de l'augmentation du prix
de l'immobilier tout les éléments qui
abondent directement et ça vaut pour les
dispositifs d'incitation fiscale d'où la
limitation sur montant des loyers de
manière j'allais dire évidente sur le
prix fonds ont eu pour conséquence ces
dernières années peut faire augmenter
les prix à la fois à l'acquisition mais
également à la location je suis je vous
avoue être un peu surprise par votre
question sur les garanties d'emprunt des
organismes hlm pour la bonne et simple
raison que ces garanties sont donc
apporté par les communes mais en cas de
défaillance des communes par la cg deux
hells qui aujourd'hui n'a absolument
aucune difficulté à garantir aucun
organisme
oui mais cette garantie existe un donc
cette garantie y est qui est restituée à
l'issue et cette garantie existait
ne présente aucune difficulté à être
mobilisés enfin pour ce qui est de la
demande monsieur le sénateur les choses
ont été votés il s'agit d'un dispositif
sur l'année 2013 qui vise justement à ne
pas mesurer le triennal 2011 2013 au
titre de la loi votée le 18 janvier mais
bien uniquement l'année 2013 les deux
précédentes années et en évalue au titre
de la loi précédente
si madame la ministre je crois que ces
précisions en tous les cas les chiffres
que vous avez donnée concernant la
performance énergétique ou la rénovation
au niveau énergie j'aime faire un petit
calcul si on investigue 17000 euros sur
15 ans même si on empruntait laisse en
pensant à leur cas mais les 1350 d'abord
on est bien à quoi je fais un petit
calcul de tête on doit rembourser sur 15
ans un taux d'impôt chance de nous mener
à 20000 euros
alors vous parlez d'une économie de 100
euros par mois et donc les 20000 / 15
ans ça nous conduit à 1300 pardon à 133
euros par mois de remboursement et donc
il ya un delta positif pour que les gens
investissent faut qu'ils d'abord faut
qu'ils aient la capacité d'un
d'emprunter et c'est là que le but qu'on
bute mais le calcul que vous donnez
démontrent que l'économie de charges aux
fins de de chauffage peut être
avantageux par rapport au rand lancement
de l'emprunt
c'est à ça qu'il faut arriver au moins
l'égalité sinon un avantage et le
scénario sur lequel nous travaillons
c'est c'est le scénario sur lequel nous
travaillons pour mettre en place un
tiers financeurs qui justement aura la
capacité d'apporter les fonds pour
pouvoir permettre les travaux en se
remboursant sur les économies d'énergie
réalisées si madame monsieur vaugrenard
et ensuite j'ai cru comprendre que
carcassonne voulait la parole oui oui
mais pardon ah oui il est revenu en
deuxième semaine
monsieur vaugrenard vous avez la parole
j'ai juste une question est d'abord 3
romain enfin à peu près là bras pidement
je pense que l'ensemble du dispositif
qui nous aident explosé depuis quelque
temps par madame la ministre montre le
souci d'efficacité et notamment en
direction des publics fragiles tragique
fragilisé vous l'avais dit en direction
des ménages également avec l'incitation
aux économies d'énergie la question qui
se posera quand même c'est avec
l'ensemble du secteur bancaire pour voir
s'il y aura une facilité aussi à
emprunter ce qui pose un autre problème
et enfin la facilité quand même en
direction du bâtiment et travaux publics
en général avec les deux mesures que
vous avez évoqué la pause normative
je crois qu'elle est extrêmement attendu
la pause normative et la tva à 5% on
aurait pu gagner trois mois si on avait
écouté la haute-assemblée voici quelque
temps du bon
mieux vaut tard que jamais la question
que je pose c'est par rapport au nouveau
dispositif de réduction d'impôt en
faveur du de l'investissement locatif
donc du dispositif qui porte votre nom
avec les nouveaux zonages qui parfois
pose problème un certain nombre de
collectivités et donc je pense qu'il
serait intéressant vraiment de que des
consignes soient donnés au niveau des
préfectures parce que c'est le préfet
qui dans un premier temps donne un avis
pour qu'il y ait un maximum de souplesse
et qu'il soit tenu compte de quelques
particularités suivant les localisations
je vais vous citer un exemple la ville
de saint nazaire actuellement à 26% de
locatif social
elle se dirige systématiquement dans les
différents programmes à hauteur de 30%
avec à la fois locatifs réalisés par les
bailleurs sociaux à la fois l'accession
à la propriété pour les propriétaires
qui n'ont pas forcément énormément de
moyens et le souhait c'était bien
entendu que le dispositif duflot puisse
entrer dans cette c3 c3 offre en quelque
sorte
or saint nazaire est passé en zone
curieusement zone b2 et du coup ça pose
des difficultés de financement et
d'accessibilité par rapport au locatif
privé donc le souhait et la demande
forte des élus et de cette ville mais je
cite cet exemple mais j'ai rencontré
d'autres exemples ailleurs cette je
n'irai c'est un sujet d'école en quelque
sorte
donc la question est ce que vous pensez
qu'il est possible d'avoir un minimum de
souplesse pour proroger si possible
dispositif qui l'a été pour ce qui
concerne cette ville jusqu'en juin 2012
pour que ce soit prorogée jusqu'en 2016
mais c'est pas un cas particulier je
souligne ça existe dans d'autres dans
d'autres villes de manière à ce que le
logement locatif privé maîtriser doivent
fasse partie de l'offre qui existe par
ailleurs la particularité de ce secteur
c'est qu'en plus il va bénéficier de
commandes importantes au niveau de la
construction navale de développement de
l'aéronautique également qui n'existe
pas qu'à toulouse parce qu'elle est
tronçon qui sont réalisés à nantes et
saint nazaire avec la possibilité
d'avoir de nouvelles constructions de
logements et du coup là la tension qui
existait peu voici six mois ou un an
risque d'exister et d'être plus forte
par ailleurs la proximité d'un littoral
attractif risque d'accroître cette
tension même ses différentes de
l'attention qu'on peut évoquer
habituellement par rapport uniquement
locatif social
donc bref est ce que vous pensez qu'il
est possible dans le cas de ce
dispositif et de ce nouveau zonage
d'avoir
un minimum de souplesse et d'entendre
les élus lorsqu'ils font une demande
particulière de modification de zonage
c'est prévu par dérogation par le préfet
à mon cher collègue monsieur courteau
merci monsieur le président oui j'ai
l'habitude de dire que le principal
gisement d'énergie en france était celui
des économies d'énergie je le redis
encore aujourd'hui et j'ajoute qu'il est
d'importance dans le secteur du logement
donc madame la ministre excellente
initiative que celle qui consiste à
mettre l'accent sur les économies
d'énergie ce qui constitue par ailleurs
un formidable gisement également
d'emplois pouvez vous m'en dire un petit
peu plus sur le redimensionnement du
sehy d'aider le crédit d'impôt
développement durable
je vois que des précisions ne paraissent
utiles car le seuil des dettes un
instrument effectivement intelligent
mais qui a été réduit au cours de ces
dernières années
une façon à mon avis trop importante
vous avez dit qu'il serait cumulable
avec l'éco ptz et c'est une excellente
chose deuxième deuxième question la
précarité énergétique
ça c'est un vrai problème des mesures
ont été prises dans le cadre de la loi
sous verre la transition
loi qui est entre les mains du conseil
constitutionnel d'ailleurs avec
l'extension détail sociaux à 8 millions
de personnes et la trêve hivernale bon
il ne reste pas moins que
l'accompagnement des ménages dans la
rénovation de leur logement et notamment
des fameux logements passoires s'avère
être une nécessité
vous avez annoncé mille en bas salaires
ça c'est une bonne réponse simplement
une question est ce que ce nombre sera
suffisant si on le rapporte au niveau de
chaque département
merci comme ce n'est pas monsieur marc
daunis dans la ministre the suite et élu
d'un département où on est plus en se
portant du on est un secteur hyper tendu
bien et quand je vois les mesures qui
sont actuellement en discussions et
propositions
j'allais dire merci et bravo parce que
derrière c'est un frein au développement
économique qui est colossal
d'abord le problème du logement et
deuxièmement sont des drames humains et
pour être beau couple on n'a pas le
temps j'irai très concrètement trois
trois sujets la première des mesures
administratives à simplifier que ce soit
en termes de développement économique en
termes de logement nous arrivons
aujourd'hui à une situation qui est un
de nabeul surtout dans des départements
où vous avez si mon collègue courteau où
vous avez la loi montagne qui rejoint la
loi littoral où vous avez des vallées
qui rentre dans la
dans la mer cela devient aujourd'hui
ingérable quand vous avez en plus des
secteurs où les pprif ont été faits il
ya de cela quelques temps et où il y à
un blocage objectif rgpp oblige puisque
services d'état 10 nous n'avons plus le
temps pour mettre en révision le pprif
on a aujourd'hui un gel du territoire
dans des communes qui au delà des
problème de volonté politique
ancien ou actuel où il y avait une
volonté de ne pas faire de logement
social sont aujourd'hui devant une très
grande difficulté donc j'aimerais madame
la ministre qu'il y ait
l'interministériel et des consignes
qu'ils soient données aux préfets pour
que très rapidement on puisse avoir des
libérations qui s'effectue par des
procédures administratives en ce sens
que ce soit au niveau des pprif de
certains ont eu tous même transitoire un
même mais à un moment donné qu'ils
puissent je pense juste un exemple
simplication de l'urbanisme la bf réputé
réputé favorable au bout de moi très
bien dans un périmètre inscrit je le vis
très directement sur ma commune qu'est
ce qui se passe en halte toutes les
instructions qui sont arrivés saisine de
la bf
il n'a pas le temps il n'est pas en
périmètre directement inscrits mais il a
la vie qui doit être donné c'est pas
stratégiques à cet endroit
bien qu est-ce qui fait il donne pas
résultat nous attendons que la vie soit
réputé favorable c'est-à-dire le délai
d'instruction prend deux mois au lieu du
mois précédent qui est demain alors je
prends des petites mesures comme ça très
simple qui bloque je pourrais développer
avec les ac
j'étais juste une absurdité sur une zac
cent mille mètres carrés shon d'accord
on passe au dossier après quatre ans de
bagarre et une des huppes et valant mise
en compatibilité du pl eu pour cent
mille mètres carrés shon on va enfin
pouvoir passer
au dossier de réalisation d'ici un an et
ont fait un environnement une étude
environnementale globale à étude
d'impact
on a tous les éléments très bien parfait
qu'est ce qui va se passer le jour il ya
le dépôt du permis de construire
fouilles à une surface commerciale qui
fait environ supérieur à 40 mille mètres
carrés shon alors qu'elle est prévue
totalement dans l'étude d'impact
initiale dans le projet où tout est est
bien le pétitionnaire va devoir refaire
l'étude environnementale puisqu'on mais
les procédures avaient justement si ça
après les ordonnances nous arrivons à
l'enlever et j'espère que c'est pas en
études cas par cas parce que je me méfie
de l'amendement étude cas par cas il y a
au passage
eh bien nous pourrons gagner un an parce
que l'étude en question prendrait un an
je pourrais développer
on n'a pas le temps je voudrais conclure
par un troisième point sur la vente hlm
sur la vente hlm tout à l'heure qu'est
ce qui a été dit
cette question peut être importante pour
le vente aux locataires de leur
propriété pour concourir à une certaine
forme de mixité sociale pourquoi parce
que dans ces habitats qui sont en train
de vieillir atteint dans notre secteur
sata des années 70 1 qu'est ce qui se
passe et vient nous avons
progressivement une paupérisation parce
que les couches les plus
zézé de selous branche sociale s'en vont
et les personnes entrantes
d'où une déqualification entre
guillemets et une perte de mixité
sociale dramatique
la seule réponse que nous avons pu
aujourd'hui à porter elle est par une
vente du patrimoine en partie mais et
c'est là où je vais venir deux
contreparties essentiel un rénovation
énergétique et travaux préalables
sinon qu'est ce qu'on a en amont sinon
qu'est-ce qu'on a derrière on a le
problème de la copropriété dégradée et
j'aimerais que dans les procédures que
vous mettez en place cela puisse y
figurer quelque part le deuxième élément
c'est une batterie dont la missa dans
une charte avec le bel les bailleurs qui
impliqua collectivités locales qui fixe
les montants de la décote puisque on a
la possibilité entre plus et moins 35%
on s'est calé sur les 30 35 en
contrepartie aussi des rénovations qui
sont faites clause anti spéculatif pour
éviter des effets d'aubaine et de
revente avec un droit de préemption qui
demeure à la collectivité ou dans dans
les mains du bailleur et accompagnement
par syndic de gestion accompagnement sur
la partie de gestion et jean n'a pas le
temps je vous mettrai tout cela ma chère
collègue de m mes chers collègues et
badham la ministre dans une dans une
note aux dispositions merci je croyais
que c'était un match entre madame
cherche monsieur calvet et monsieur de
nice non c'est plus que ça monsieur le
noir qu'elle n'en excusez moi mon cher
collègue mais vous étiez sortie au
moment je regardais les demandes de
parole vous revenez je veux allez-y sur
le président pourrait discuter du doigt
tout dire de ma vie privée
vous voulez vraiment savoir non je
craque véritable fille est ce que le
fait de savoir qui était d'ordre un
autre groupe d'étude qui s'occupait du
cheval a alors réuni j'ai deux questions
à vous poser
le programme ambitieux que vous avez
affiché en ce qui concerne la rénovation
des bâtiments la performance énergétique
suppose que les entreprises soient au
rendez vous les entreprises du bâtiment
mais également les entreprises qui
proposent et installe des appareils dont
la pompe à chaleur mais combien d'autres
combien d'autres y compris les hélices
qui sont censés apporter des kilowatts
et des kilowatts
alors vous devrez simplement ont posé la
question de savoir il n'est pas
judicieux je le fais vraiment dans un
sens constructif comme d'habitude
d'ailleurs qui consisterait à est ce
qu'il y est un travail de fond mené avec
votre collègue à la fois de l'éducation
nationale mais surtout celui qui est en
charge de la formation professionnelle
de l'apprentissage pour que d'abord les
entreprises puissent former des jeunes
des moins jeunes à ces nouveaux métiers
on peut parler de nouveaux métiers et
que ensuite puisse être accordée
je dirais une sorte de label permettant
aux consommateurs de savoir à qui l'afer
le nombre de fois où vous êtes demandés
personnes qui sont fait avoir un
technico commercial qui n'a rien de
technique aussi rien de commercial
sauf qu yvan
yvan des appareils qui ne sont pas
forcément performants et ces gens se
font avoir et souvent en sont victimes
des personnes plus modestes et des
personnes âgées
deuxième question alors qui est très
ponctuel madame la ministre
j'ai participé à l'inauguration d'un
d'un lotissement de la mise à
disposition par un organisme hlm
d'habitation qui avait été très bien
conçue très bien construite et alors m'a
été posée le problème suivant concernant
le label bbc donc sur les bâtiments
performants en l'occurrence ce label n'a
pas été accordée parce que les maisons
étaient chauffés à l'électricité avec
l'appareil d'ailleurs sur lesquels tout
le monde convient qu'il y avait une
performance qui était au rendez vous et
le refus étaient opposés parce qu'il
aurait fallu que ce soit du gas
il eût fallu que ces maisons fussent
chauffés au gaz pour que bon or dans le
milieu rural et il n'est pas facile
d'avoir le raccordement mais alors si
vous infirmez parce que lorsque nous
avons reçu madame la ministre
le président de habiter mieux
je lui ai posé ce problème il avait
convenu que la réglementation avait été
trop loin
l'édile belle balancier est allé trop
loin il faut revenir du bon côté donc
j'avais cru comprendre les coûts tant
que le problème posé avec quelques
fondements alors madame la ministre je
vais le faire avec vous je n'attends pas
forcément une réponse maintenant si je
l'avais après cette réunion je serai
évidemment très très satisfait
si monsieur dit la merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre merci pour
ce pour ces mesures qui me paraissent
tout très très importante et est
efficace mais si j'avais une mesure à
retenir c'est évidemment la tva à 5% en
me souvenant à la suite de claude berri
de bach nous étions un certain deux
sénatrices et sénateurs a plaidé très
vivement ça nous a été un peu accroché
pour cette mesure et je pense que c'est
bien qu'elle arrive enfin je dirais mais
ces mesures on double efficacité elles
sont à la fois
elles vont permettre la construction de
logements c'est à dire de dire oui à des
gens qui demande de logements ce qu'elle
est déjà énorme mais elles vont
effectivement comme vous le disiez
relancer le secteur du bâtiment et cette
relance des entreprises du bâtiment non
délocalisables pourrait peut-être à mon
sens s'accompagner d'une espèce d'esprit
non pas de donnant-donnant mai mais
presque c'est à dire qu'il faudrait
inciter pour le moins les maîtres
d'ouvragé à inscrire des clauses
d'insertion sociale dans leur appel
d'offres parce qu'il est quand même
assez dommageable de voir des palissades
et des grues arrivée dans des secteurs
ou de chauffage le pardon le chômage est
et est très important c'est
malheureusement souvent la khl le
logement social se construit et que la
population locale non n'en bénéficient
pas elle passe à côté des palissades
mais elle n'en bénéficient pas de même
pour les petites entreprises ou les
entreprises de taille moyenne qui
souvent voit le marché pris part des
entreprises générales après le peuvent
rentrer par une sous traitance mais
keane qui étrangle un petit peu donc
peut-être je sais que c'est difficile
pour avoir été moi même maître d'ouvragé
mais peut-être leur demander au sida
l'autre dalle au tir lors leurs appels
d'offres de façon à ce que des
entreprises locales puissent aussi
participé à cette relance sur merci
madame la ministre devrait peut-être des
règles générales lotissement monsieur
l'abbé oui monsieur le président la
ministre
deux mots de satisfaction d'abord
ensuite un questionnement et ensuite
porte parole d'un mécontentement
la satisfaction d'abord là votre
détermination madame lamy
str sur ce sujet qui est un sujet
d'urgence l'efficacité du général de
proposer par par les mesures qui nous
sont proposés aussi lorsqu'un ministre
nous nous fait une promesse on attend de
voir madame la ministre
claude dilain lisa et à tout à l'heure
on en a eu une soirée un peu difficile
en séance lorsqu'il s'agissait là une
dernière de débattre du de la tva sur
logement social c'était s'étaient
tendues et difficiles je vous sentez pas
à l'aise non plus à la sortie vous aviez
promis que dès 2013 les choses seraient
rétablies ce qui a été fait donc ses
motifs de satisfaction à questionnement
par rapport qui va dans le sens de ce
que nous a dit le collègue yannick
vaugrenard tous talents dans
l'application des possibles dérogations
du dispositif qui porte
historiquement votre nom maintenant le
dispositif duflot
donc il ya les zones a et b1 il n'y a
pas de y'a pas de soucis pour ce qui est
du zonage b2 il y à des territoires qui
sont qui sont communauté d'agglomération
qui ont un plh donc là l'élève les
services déconcentrés de l'état en
région ont mené un travail pour voir
quels étaient les communes les plus
tendues sachant que toutes les communes
ne pouvait pas être éligibles et on se
rend compte là que par rapport à
l'esprit du plh il
l'application stricte sur les communes
les plus tendus par mille étangs du va
faire quelque chose d'extrêmement d'
extrêmement injuste à savoir les
communes de première couronne qui sont
moins tendue que les que les que les
communes urbaines dans la pratique
maintenant le fait en centre bourg en
centre petite ville de faire du
collectif comme ces demandes et en
termes de gammes de densification et
dans le collectif la mixité
il y a le logement social il y a le
logement en accession et il y a le
locatif privé qui contribuent à
l'économie générale alors le deux
agglomérations que je peux représenter
ici vannes
et puis lorient cap l'orient cap
l'orient demande à ce que ce soit
l'ensemble du territoire couvert par le
plh qu'ils soient pris en compte et
propose en mesure d'économie parce qu'il
faut
il faut aussi trouver les moyens au lieu
de haut lieu du fait que ce soit 80 %
des logements qui bénéficient du
dispositif qu'il n'y ait plus que 50%
sur ce territoire là je sais pas si
c'est applicable
de telle sorte que la mx 6 cette mixité
là elle puisse être plus plus partagés
entre les les communes ayant étant sur
le même plh
voilà c'est un petit pull je me ferais
auprès de vous plus explicite
prochainement et il le mécontentement
c'est un collègue maire lorsque l'on est
maire on a rit on lorsqu'on arrive mer
on arrive avec une situation donnée donc
élu en 2008 une équipe avec beaucoup de
retard en logement social des efforts
énormes à 30% surtout des opérations et
d or d effort financier de la
collectivité également pour pour
rattraper le retard et arrive sur 2013
une pénalité de cinquante mille euros et
mon collègue maire me fait savoir mais
c'est autant qu'il n'ira pas dans le
temps dans le logement social
donc il donne enfin il demande à voir
s'il ya possibilité d'une dérogation
merci
bon si on traduit préfet bon ok moon
non il ya une erreur quelque part du
type des subventions qu'il apporte donc
si les subventionneurs accord n'a pas
possible gbowee a marre mais c'est bien
tenté mais c'est faux s'est passé pas
joël s'est pas jouée non mais madame
nico oui madame la ministre certainement
qu'un certain nombre d'aidés remarque je
vais faire vous vous avez déjà apporté
les réponses vous avez commencé votre
entrevue avait en nous disant que le
secteur du bâtiment était en situation
difficile alors que nous avions besoin
de logements sociaux et donc qu'il y a
de deux choses qui doivent se rencontrer
et vous avez insisté sur le fait qu' il
était difficile pour les personnes
d'accéder au logement de qualité dans
les zones tendues
et là je voudrais attirer votre
attention sur le fait qu'il est aussi
très difficile dans certaines zones qui
ne sont pas tendues
c'est à dire les régions les zones
rurales d'accéder à du logement de
qualité et dans cette mesure la tva à 5%
s'appliquera-t-elle à la rénovation de
l'habitat dans des zones peu denses dans
les zones non tendues où le logement
social c'est aussi le logement des
petits propriétaires qui n'ont pas les
moyens souvent de faire des travaux et
cela pose la question ce ne sont pas des
logements qui sont qualifiés de logement
social mais en tant qu' ils sont souvent
propriétaires mais avec des très très
faible revenu et je pense qu'il serait
bon de prendre en compte les revenus des
propriétaires dans la définition du
logement social et de ceux qui peuvent
bénéficier de ce taux à 5% et mon autre
question elle avait trait aux
ambassadeurs de la performance
énergétique dans quel
collectivités ou dans quels organismes
seront ils amenés oui à être hébergée de
manière à ce que les demandeurs soient
puissent avoir accès à leurs services
facilement et enfin je rejoins avant
collègues le noir quant à la formation
je crois que c'est une priorité
concernant les métiers du bâtiment pour
pouvoir répondre de façon correcte aux
travaux qui sont amenés dans les
différentes rénovations et travaux de
performance énergétique
merci mais mes chers collègues je pense
que nous poserons des questions monsieur
dominique braye demain concernant
l'hébergement des ambassadeurs je pense
que la nappe pourrait être un site
privilégié
je ne sais pas on leur posera la
question et votre j'attends votre
réponse aussi madame la ministre
le dernier intervenant n est pas le
moindre jeu monsieur mirassou très
rapidement et à marge du débat madame
ministre même si vous lever à aborder un
petit peu moi je vais vous qu'est le
logement d'urgence qui est une
préoccupation singulièrement milieu
urbain qui taraude tous les élus locaux
on connaît familles qui vont de
logements logements souvent qu'ils en
trouvent pas dire est où il explique que
d'un côté c'est les élus locaux et de
l'autre n'ont cédé ressort de la
préfecture de l'état et total ça finit
avec l'implication active déterminante
cette même association par l'occupation
illicite heure locale ce qui n'arrange
ni ceux qui occupent illicitement
locales et encore moins ceux à qui
appartient locale
je veux savoir où vous allez être mon
ami c'est votre réflexion sur ce dossier
monsieur loup pendant les aixois en
présence se demanda mains du jour oui
c'est le président c'est pas gentil pour
les loups non mais vous avez seule la
parole comme vous êtes arrivé en retard
très rapidement mais j'ai suivi tout le
débat devant de mon bureau c'est
retransmis à 6 si je peux citer y
compris vos calculs approximatifs sur
les 17 lits et les 138 3 0 que nous
aurions à rembourser mensuellement
je me suis dit ça se voit que c'était
universitaire c'est à peu près non je
vous remercie monsieur bertrand vous
pouvez poser vos questions il est simple
question à peu place à non pas du côté
les propriétaires des bailleurs et
pratiquement pas de deux des
particuliers c'est à dire du côté des
entreprises moi je trouve que tout ce
que c'est madame la ministre est
excellent et simplement du côté des
entreprises alors dans les honneurs où
il n'y a pas d'autres économies fils
finalement que ces petites et moyennes
entreprises du bâtiment et des travaux
publics et où finalement la commande
publique s'est réduit celle des
collectivités territoriales les procédés
ou les procédures et citati vallée du
dispositif favorise à la construction
qui peut loi scellier ou deux ça se sont
réduits et ils sont extrêmement
désemparés or dans des zones fragiles
ça constitue l'essentiel des entreprises
des petites entreprises ou des moyennes
qui vont de 5 10 15 20 et 30 employés et
eux ils ne font plus de programme et
donc est alors qu'il soutient
grande-vallée conneries donc qu'est ce
qu'on pourrait faire pour eux madame la
ministre et sa chaîne qui produirait
aussi des logements moyen de gamme se
rejoignent un peu la question d'un
collègue madame micoud et qu' il
faudrait trouver un procès des
incitatifs à ce cas il avait alors
appris non pas des conneries ernéen
thenergie et du logement lui même mais
il en va de l'emploi pour une petite
zone parce qu'on n'a pas d'industrie de
remplacement dans les grandes
agglomérations en ville il ya une
économie dit
ainsi multiples et en tant qu'un
souffrent ceux d'autres prennent le
relais par exemple les services aux
personnes
nous faisons nôtre et rurales ou ip
rural on la passe alors il faudrait
peut-être leur mission puisque vous
faites preuve d'inventivité à cet égard
elle vote est aussi quelque chose dit
madame la ministre
avec cette salle de questions alors
saint nazaire alors je réponds à foix
pour saint nazaire vannes lorient et le
club db2 donc quand même ce qu'il faut
se dire c'est pourquoi nous avons abouti
à cette situation pour une raison très
simple c'est que le constat qui a été
fait sur le scellier c'est qu'on aboutit
à des situations qui sont en situation
critique j'ai aussi des élus alors
évidemment ils le disent moi qu'ils
m'expliquent qu'ils sont très ennuyés
parce qu'il ya des opérations qui font
concurrence au logement social
parce que les propriétaires sont
tellement désespérés de ne pas louer et
donc du coup de perdre leur
défiscalisation de se retrouver en
situation de surendettement mais en
situation de de très fragile
financièrement qu'ils sont prêts à louer
à n'importe quel prix du coup dans de
mauvaises conditions des immeubles à
moitié vide je vous passe les détails
donc il y avait vraiment la nécessité
pour nous on est très vigilants pour
qu'on construise des logements et pas
des opérations de défiscalisation
là les choses sont très claires sur la
volonté du gouvernement donc ça c'était
c'est un point important quand même pour
dire les choses
aujourd'hui au moment nous parlons
toutes les communes b2 sont éligibles au
dispositif avant le 30 juin
les mines mais ça c'est la réalité
justement pour ne pas qu'ils aient un
effet d'un coup très brutale ou parliez
madame lamure de transition nous l'avons
fait de la même manière pour la question
des zones b2 avant le 30 juin
les préfets doivent prendre des arrêtés
relative aux communes qui resteront
éligible en zone b2 et elles le seront
jusqu'au jusqu'au 31 décembre 2013
l'objectif en lien avec les
observatoires c'est d'avoir un pilotage
très fin donc de pouvoir juger justement
par rapport à ce que vous indiquez
monsieur l'abbé sur la proposition de la
commune de lorient alors inventer des
dispositifs spécifiques avec 50% de
non-ps c'est intéressant sur le papier
c'est très très compliqué à gérer d'un
point de vue national donc l'idée qu est
la nôtre aujourd'hui c'est de pouvoir
piloter finement les communes par le
biais des observatoires c'est à dire
d'avoir des critères qui se déploieront
sur les territoires sans avoir besoin de
remonter à des zonages c'est bien tous
les objectifs du système d'observatoire
des loyers de pouvoir piloter
quand l'encadrement des loyers en cas de
nécessité y compris de leur serrer sur
certains territoires que ces questions
de d'autres dispositifs d'avant
un pilotage fin et réactif de la
politique du logement l'objectif est
donc après le déploiement d'ici la fin
de l'année des observatoires qu'au 1er
janvier 2014
le dispositif s'applique en fonction pas
d'un nouveau zonage mais bien de
critères retenus y compris en matière de
tension sur le logement intermédiaire
par exemple territoire par territoire
donc voilà la réponse que je peux vous
faire aujourd'hui le dispositif
s'applique en zone b2 jusqu'au 30 juin
à partir du 30 juin il faut une
dérogation signé par le préfet et à
l'issue de cette dérogation au 1er
janvier 2014 nous nous appuierons sur
les observatoires nous réfléchissons
parallèlement la possible voilà pour
l'audition de la ministre cécile duflot
sur le plan d'urgence en faveur du
bâtiment et sur la question de la
rénovation thermique à suivre l'émission
politique de la rédaction de public
sénat preuve par 3 qui reçoit ce soir le
président du modem françois bayrou bonne
soirée à tous